i think this whole woke thing has gone
too far
wolf just means that you are current you
are aware and you are sensitive
um so
if someone has a problem with somebody
being aware of issues
then that's pure ignorance
free speech first amendment i mean
they're not they're not being they're
not being abusive they're not being
physical
they're just they're participating in
their first amendment right i think i
think
you know my personal opinion since sarah
palin we've gotten mean in this country
i think everyone should be welcome
everywhere and we don't want them here
we don't we don't want to turn this
state ever your governor
is
an idiot
our governor desantis we love him most
people don't love him so i think people
are just trying to come down and and row
up things here in um in in florida
people should be welcomed rather than
disregarded like that and being told
they can't come down here because
it it's like everyone should be welcome
anywhere as long as they're not causing
anyone any harm if somebody disappeared
walk you're not welcome it means that
you have no tolerance to people who are
different from you
you know they always try to give florida
a bad name saying you know what i mean
so they're just continuing to try to
just defame us that's all and like the
term woke when they refer to them as
that
i don't really think it's like
a positive connotation i just think
people should let people be we should
talk to each other more we should listen
to each other more and maybe this
country would not be in the terrible
state that it's in